تداول رواد مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي مقطع
فيديو يمثل الامريكيه وهي تنهارو باكيه
وكشفت عن خسارتها نصف ثروتها المقدره ب 60
مليون دولار بسبب الازمه المصرفيه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه نتابع
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مشاهد صادمه في شبه جزيره القرم اظهرت
تلاميذ في مدرسه يتدربون على تركيب اسلحه
حقيقيه وذكر الرئيس الاداره التابعه
لروسيا في شبه جزيره القرن ان اكثر من 60
طالبا شاركوا في هذه التدريبات
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو متداول على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي لعامل روسي يتخلص من حوالي نصف
مليون دولار من نافذه منزله قبل مداهمه
الشرطه سرقها من تركيا خلال عمليات
الانقاذ بعد الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب
البلاد
[موسيقى]
مقطع فيديو متداول لعاصفه رمليه كانت قويه
ومخيفه في سلطنه عمان ورغم خطورتها كان
عدد من الاطفال يركضون وسطها غير مكترثين
بخطورتها ما اثار ردوده فعل عديده بمواقع
التواصل واستغراب البعض اقتحام الاطفال
للزوبعه
كان هذا كل شيء لليوم الى اللقاء